Mong qua 2 năm tháng 5 năm 2020, thông tin từ công an tình bật liệu, đơn vị đã tạm sữa hình sự châu văn mai,
3 mốt tuổi 1 thí sát xa dài, bình bật liệu để đưa tra về hình ví dứt người.
Trước đó, và tối ngày 20 năm 2020, các quan công an nhận được tin bảo của chủ nhé trọ ở ớp 2,
sát thân phòng, tí sát xa dài, về việc phát hiện một phụ nữ từ bóng tệ phòng trọc.
Nát nhân được rất định là.
Chị Tây Cà lời, sinh 5 ngày 2020, 1 ốc dễ tham, xa viên trẻ thị phố bật liệu.
Bằng các biệt pháp nghiệp vụ, các quan công an rất định nghiệp phạm là châu văn mai,
người cùng trọc với nạn nhân, nên tin hình hả sữa hình gấp.
Tại các quan công an, may 2 dần sống như vội trọng với lời tệ nhện trọc.
Hỉ lời đặc mằng thay.
Gió không có nghỉ nghiệp uống định, may để nghỉ lời quay về sống với gia đình,
biến tác khu của khả năng chăm sóc lời.
Ngày 20 năm 2020, xa mốt tưởng bóng phát trong việc tối vụ lời quay về với gia đình,
may đạ sát xa khải sĩ lời.
Được biết, may zà tù ngày 20 năm 2020, về tội của y về tưởng biết không nghĩ nghiệp.